[Music]
few experiences in childhood have a more
enduring impact than the relationships
we have with our siblings research shows
that having a good relationship with
your brother or sister can reduce
feelings of loneliness depression and
anxiety but a new survey finds that
parental favoritism the perception that
there is a favorite child in the family
may negatively influence sibling
relationships think sibling rivalry 40
of americans with siblings say that
their parents had a favorite child in
the family why does this matter
lots of reasons but here's three
first it increases feelings of social
isolation
americans report that their parents had
a favorite child report feeling lonely a
lot more often growing up
second it damages sibling relationships
this group also reports that they were
not as close to their siblings growing
up
third it undercuts trust in parents
this group was also much less likely to
turn to their parents for support
growing up instead relying on friends or
having no one to rely on at all
research has shown that parental
favoritism is universally problematic
and not just for those who aren't the
favorite
growing up do you think your parents had
a favorite child let us know in our poll
also let us know what other topics you'd
like scholars to cover in 60 seconds and
be sure to like and subscribe for more
research and videos from aei
[Music]